yeah fazer yes now I'll probably give it
back because I stole it
who hasn't food galaxy jay's your
commander is on deck it is a touchstone
for filmmakers of a certain generation
it is a broad comedy of course but it
also has a real heart you shine the
moment in the movie where he says it's
real and the kid goes I knew it it's all
real I knew it
that was means I I knew it they had fun
doing the movie and you can see that
there is no adult supervision or very
little I just want that directors cut me
cuz we cussed now Jim would come to the
set usually a little bit late and make
vomiting and farting noises just no
professionalism whatsoever that Dallin
was just like I won't laugh at him I
refused to laugh instead of judging me
he accepted me because well your
wretched father is maybe pro-market
it's really a very sophisticated movie
they found every joke found every
exciting moment yeah they had every
great line you could possibly have
by grabthar's I'm what to savings it
just couldn't be better
somebody does something first and a
small number of people go wow that's
amazing and the larger culture ignores
it Galaxy Quest was way ahead of its
time I don't think you could do a film
today about the teen nerd and say he was
the outcast there's a hero within all of
us
galaxy quests came along and said these
people are heroes too they can actually
be at the center of the story for the
most part the Nerds have inherited the
earth so they were right
[Music]
my whole pitch has gone down in eighteen
years I don't think I could do that hey
screen junkies click to learn how to see
the full documentary
[Music]